Інтерв'ю Вахтанга Кікабідзе Deutsche Welle
викликало бурхливу реакцію серед низки
російських політиків і громадських діячів.
Перша реакція на слова грузинського актора
надійшла з Ради Федерації від голови комісії
з інформаційної політики Олексія Пушкова.
Вкрай негативною була й реакція колеги Пушкова
Франца Клінцевича. У тому ж дусі висловилася й низка діячів культури,
серед них - співак Юрій Антонов, письменник Едуард Лимонов, журналіст Володимир Соловйов
і гуморист Євген Петросян.
А голова фракції компартії РФ в Держдумі Геннадій Зюганов
навіть звинуватив Кікабідзе в обслуговуванні Вашингтона.
Режисер і перший заступник голови комітету Держдуми,  комуніст Володимир Бортко
заявив, що його дивує заява Кікабідзе, адже він
"зробив свою кар'єру завдяки Радянському Союзу
і повинен бути йому вдячним"
І все ж деякі діячі культури підтримали Кікабідзе.
Заяву Олексія Пушкова розкритикувала відома актриса Олена Проклова,
яка також знімалася у фільмі "Міміно".
Вона назвала слова сенатора "дурними".
За Кікабідзе також заступився письменник Віктор Шендерович.
Вахтанга Кікабідзе також підтримав і колишній президент Грузії
Міхеіл Саакашвілі. "Це не тільки великий артист,
він, безумовно, великий громадянин", - написав Саакашвілі.